with four kids there's always some
activity you know
heidi klum got it from her mama and
heidi's 16 year old daughter
yeah she got it from her mama too i just
love being
together with my loved ones and that's
all you know
that is important really at the end of
the day on sunday the 47 year old model
hit up
instagram to share this family pic with
her mom
erna klum and her daughter lainey klum
posing side by side
in the mirror the three generation shot
was snapped on the set of heidi and
lainey's photo shoot for vogue germany
and honestly the ladies look more like
sisters than grandma
mom and daughter thank you so much laney
whose dad is italian businessman flavio
briatori
posed with her model mama on the january
february 2021
cover of vogue germany and shared a
sweet behind-the-scenes video on
instagram
calling it a very special day in the
caption
i hear myself in you when i'm laughing
i was gonna say that i swear to god
um i see myself in you
when i'm singing as for heidi
she couldn't help but gush over the big
moment on instagram
too sharing the mommy daughter cover
alongside a lengthy post
quote i'm so proud of you and not
because you chose this path
i know that no matter which way you go
it will be your own
you always know exactly what you want
and what you don't want
you are not a mini-me and i'm happy for
you that you can now show who
you are and the sweet sentiment didn't
stop there
heidi added that she knows being her
daughter is not always easy and her
little girl never had the opportunity to
grow up normally
but she's managed to become a
self-confident young woman who fights
for her goals
and a really great person who has her
heart in the right place
the america's got talent judge wrapped
up the post writing quote
vogue is the best way to start the
career you dream of
and even if it is a little difficult for
me to let go of you
into this world i will always do
everything so that you are happy and
that your dreams come true
i am proud to be your mom of course most
proud i'm of my four beautiful children
heidi is also the proud mama to three
other kiddos
fifteen-year-old henry fourteen-year-old
johann and eleven-year-old lou
whom she shares with her ex seal last
month heidi posted a rare snap of all
four kids together
sightseeing in germany where heidi is
filming season 16
of germany's next top model also in
attendance
heidi's hubby 31 year old tokyo hotel
musician
tom kalitz he's amazing i love him the
next day heidi celebrated johan's
birthday
writing on instagram that she is so
proud of him
what's the secret i know a lot of moms
out there want to know the secret to
co-parenting especially when you're one
place and their dad's somewhere else you
know
i mean it works it works it works you
make it work you make your own like
everything
heidi reached an agreement with seal in
august to be able to travel with her
kids to germany
according to court docs obtained by e.t
she will be with them through december
19th
and again january 9th through february
23rd
a source told et at the time quote the
children want to be with their mother
she is bringing them back for a few
weeks at christmas to spend time with
their father
you